und erfolg ganz schön hart hey leute was
genau und jetzt bekommen bei neuen video
und zwar hab ich mir gedacht so klar es
gibt ganz viele von euch die finden mich
so ganz cool so wie ich bin aber es gibt
wahrscheinlich auch den ein oder anderen
der hat so ein bisschen was gegen mich
aus zu setzen bzw
da staut sich so etwas an was man
einfach mal raus lassen will
und da habe ich mir gedacht komm ich
gebe euch mal die chance ihr könnt mit
videos schicken will mich tötet sagt wie
scheiße ich bin über vor ganz schön hart
ja ich will sachen gesteins die videos
jetzt alle zusammen an und mal gucken
was du so warum kam ich bin ganz
gespannt ich würde sagen lässt golden
state und ja bloß geht absolut die
videos wurde mir alles nett geschickt
bei specialist hier kurz einmal könnt
ihr mich gerne hätten freue ich mich
immer sehr wenn ich da dann ein paar
leute mehr hat und ja check das mal ab
ist auch eigentlich ganz cool da bin ich
sehr aktiv aber jetzt fangen wir an mit
den apps was soll ich jetzt dazu sagen
also dass sie auf jeden fall als krasse
einfallen lassen aber was mir gerade mal
so aufgefallen ist du bist dich ja
eigentlich auch ein bisschen selber
damit eine weil das heißt ja eigentlich
dass du dann einen geilen arsch ist oder
ich habe meinen arsch bezeichnet du dein
gesicht ja doch doch das stimmt das
stimmt oder nicht liege ich falsch nein
die ich nicht ein bisschen mehr
verkrafte ich noch so wie guck mal
weiter also erstmal heißt es als deine
ja immer diese leute die wie sagen das
ist voll schlechtes deutsch man das
heißt als aber ja ich weiß okay den
videos von katja dann muss man auch auf
jeden fall ein krasses wieder raus hand
um den halt so ein bisschen vom niveau
her konkurrenz zu bieten ich mein ich
könnte mich jetzt hier ausziehen also du
meist irgendwie ich bin nicht cool weil
ich mich nicht aus sie erwartet
das mache ich jetzt nicht ich musste
mein videos doch auch immer ein bisschen
niveau halten finde ich habe mir heute
schon so ein krasses shirt mit seinem
heftigen ausschnitt angezogen das jetzt
damit nicht zufrieden ist kann ich gar
nicht verstehen und meine videos sind
eigentlich doch ein bisschen besser als
die oder nicht abgesehen von den 13
jährigen jungs die sich darauf einen
runter höher es gibt auch andere seiten
so man wird sich das jetzt sagen hört
also denkt jetzt nicht ich wer sonst
werden aber ich verstehe einfach nicht
warum man für so was auf youtube geht
man wenn ihr 13 seite und es wirklich
nötig habt dann geht etwas anderes ohne
scheiß okay leute wir machen weiter fuß
haben
die auf marcel wie hässlich zum treffen
ob engel fuß haben solltest du dir auch
mal rasieren wie hässlich sind deine
fußnägel dass die gibt's doch gar keinen
sinn wo er weiß wie meine fußnägel
aussehen du stehst bestimmter füßen
getreten weiter keine kleine sache
ich bin so fame dass man möchte ich mal
anrufen kann du willst du mich anrufen
kann mich anrufen ich geb so was wie wir
halten noch nicht so gern meine nummer
ja dann bring den müll raus wo ist jetzt
deine sinn
gibt's da irgendeinen zusammenhang leute
wenn ja dann sagt es mir im moment man
das muss ich jetzt analysieren
als ich dich gesehen habe ist mir
aufgefallen dass ich den müll raus
bringen wollte wie kommt man auf so was
das heißt du hast mich gesehen und das
ist dann ich bin dein mio
alles klar also das ist wirklich was das
nimmt mich immer hart und ich meinte ich
verstehe nicht wie mitte wie kann etwas
schwul aussehen das kitzelt sagt mir was
die definition das etwas schwul aussieht
findet ihr diese blonde haare sehen
schwul aus ich denke mir so also ich
find die englisch kunst
das macht so wenn ihr findet diesen
scheiße aus also heil schwul oder so
dann lasst daumen nach unten darf und
wenn ihr findet die sind ganz okay dann
könnt ihr gern nach oben da lassen dann
sehe ich das ja so dann habe ich
vielleicht so 12.000 likes und 1000 ist
vielleicht bin ich mal gespannt deswegen
macht es auf jeden fall wenn ihr findet
scheiße doch nach unten wenn ihr findet
gut doch nach oben
du bist hässlich
ganz ehrlich keiner will ich ganz
ehrlich keiner würde ich finde heute
spaß gemacht wir quasi weiß ich nicht
also eigentlich ist so was ja nicht süß
aber ich finde da war so ein kleiner
süßer touch dabei so viel spaß guten hat
mich kann doch auch gar keinen oder also
ich kann nur halt versteht ihr oder sich
verteilt so bei jungs ist auch egal aber
das war ein cooler snap hat mir sehr
gefallen und das mit kevin blut da heißt
doch nicht ich habe auch kevins als
freunde sind alle cool ich habe doch
keine kevins als freunde
aber ich verstehe das nicht alle sind
immer gegen diese kevins es gibt
bestimmt auch nette kevins wenn du jetzt
gerade kevin heißt für dich bitte nicht
angesprochen ich mag dich und ja ich
werde dir auch oft so fertig gemacht wie
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich gesehen hat
deswegen das ist halt ganz normal bei
mir und bei kevin ja heute das war's mit
diesem video auf gefällt könnt ihr gerne
daumen nach oben da lassen halt so
bewerten frisur gut oder nicht auch auf
jeden fall daumen nach oben oder nach
unten wird mich sehr interessieren
wir sehen uns am nächsten keine ahnung
wieder ich habe es bald meine abi
klausuren deswegen kommt da nicht ganz
so viel aber danach habe ich so durch da
habe ich so durchhält aber danach sich
so durch dann geht es natürlich straight
auf die 300.000 zu habt ihr auch schon
bald erreicht glaube ich treffe den ball
ist ein gemeldet hier oben links ins
weite abonnieren ich vergessen übrigens
mit meinem letzten video da wurden meine
haare so ein bisschen gefährt wurde ich
halt bisschen gekränkt dass auf jeden
fall ab wenn es noch nicht gesehen habe
und ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
tag